вибір США компанія у Франції на повних
абортів цих районах ліля до традиційно
голосують затоках жульєн лоранто його
команда домагається мобілізований вибір
тиф за офіційного соціалісти дж на
кандидата
бенуа амон а панцир не може проблема в
тому що імідж і соціалістів zip саванний
ми йому сама дата все мураду продам ним і
на мага і муся масою до інших травня на
відвозив стане 5 руки на президентство
франсуа олланда багата вибірки поважаєте
його уряду ванні вже катастрофічним
людина здається затікала вся і готові
прийти на виступ омона доступного дня та
всі вони туго ти піти дні за партію
олланда а як не стали функція
на складні шпс не тисячам він продовжує
ми добрі справи ці поправки інша
за початку of holland прикладом кут вузол
свити above харчування одне 100th любив
проте ці люди нам вершина довіряють з
тих хто духи пуделя я соціалістичні
куля до частоти sorento вання катя жінка
отже бенуа амон на єдиний кандидат лівих
публіки і що двійнят шийки заплутування ми
вистрибнути омона виразку чаєм і по ви не
буде мат або ш1 суть реалістичного
кандидата бенуа амона на щастя
висунулася ще й жебрака, наприклад я його
мануель macron то жан-люк мало ніж знає
і мало потребу рача травня на плані ідей і
несли тусується витка дати
на стукнуло дня та спортзалі xi відсікають
виступи війну амуна є провулку
був президент вкрай реалістичний
сценарій за укутування мій омон на бар
і loshad 10 адже сотки
повний провал для правої партії у
Франції